there are many ways to support the
knights though right yeah absolutely
people going crazy with different things
there's some really cool things that
jc fernandez has been checking out
[Applause]
when it comes to supporting our vegas
golden knights you can wear a shirt
you can wear a jersey or you can get
hockey hair crazy
my name is larry we're at makeshift
union today we're going to be painting
some beards
if you're going to get hockey hair crazy
the first thing you need is spray paint
larry what kind of paint are we using
uh this is uh just temporary uh hair
spray paint
you can buy it at any party city yeah i
went and got some red and gold
and uh it's perfectly safe for uh facial
hair
however it does conduct electricity for
the next four hours so
highly flammable it's oh it is highly
planned so don't smoke that cigar when
you're going to t-mobile arena what's
the first step when spray painting
appears so i want to map out like some
cool shapes and create like a cool
design he wants to stand out of the game
but then yeah what i'm thinking is like
i do the gold as bright as possible on
the outside
and then i'll hit it with a little red
in the middle now how does it feel going
on is it does it tickle as a table
it's definitely cool and you definitely
should hold your breath
[Applause]
what do we have here so this is glitter
we're gonna spray
you know we're going for a more subtle
look here is this gold glitter yeah this
is called glitter
[Music]
now this is very uh golden night looking
the beer looks awesome the gold we got
the glitter
you have a different color there's
something missing this beautiful
red van the red band i believe this is
the desert sunset
is it i don't know works for me
[Applause]
[Music]
this looks sharp it's off centered all
right yeah who cares people are having
so much fun at the game going hockey
crazy they're not going to notice that
your hockey hair crazy is off a little
bit
also got these peel and stick
jewels and i thought
boy wouldn't these be cool to add a
little
extra emotion you're going to t-mobile
arena looking like this you're getting
on camera tonight you better
oh yeah that's a number one fan right
there ladies and gentlemen
now this is what you call hockey hair
crazy
[Applause]
[Music]
is it me or did the guy in the middle
look like he was having an allergic
reaction
game six is tomorrow night in montreal
there's a